[Music]
it's Sunday morning I think my room is
dark my head is throbbing I haven't not
in my stomach nausea mix with anxiety oh
why did I take all those tequila shots
last night why do I feel like I need to
apologize to my best friend again I
promised myself just like I did last
Sunday the going forward things will be
different no more shots I am done
feeling like this when I wake up week
after week I made these Sunday morning
promises to myself only to break them by
Friday night I just couldn't let go of
alcohol it played a huge role in my life
both socially and professionally I was
afraid that if I quit drinking I would
feel different from everyone else or
that I wouldn't be seen as part of the
group yet I knew I had to make a change
after years of struggling to keep my
Sunday morning promises I finally sought
support to quit drinking last summer and
trust me that was a change for the
better I'm sure many of you may relate
to my story it's not that dramatic just
a bunch of ugly Sunday mornings but even
so I found quitting drinking really hard
in the early days I couldn't go to bars
or be around people drinking alcohol and
I'd say I still had an easier time than
a lot of people for those with more
ingrained addiction it can be nearly
impossible to quit drinking and if you
are able to quit you face a world that
too often revolves around alcohol
getting sober is helped me understand
that keeping alcohol in such a prevalent
role in society disadvantages and
excludes those who don't drink
whether people abstain due to pregnancy
religious beliefs recovery or personal
preference we are creating a divide that
keeps many non-drinkers out of our most
important conversations this exclusion
whether intentional or not
means we're missing out on the valuable
untapped perspectives of many of these
people
and we are not talking about a small
group of people here in fact alcohol org
a subsidiary of American addiction
centers estimates that 30 percent of US
adults don't consume any alcohol and
this number continues to rise as
Millennials become more and more
health-conscious there's even a new
trend taking hold called the sober
curious movement with the non-drinking
portion of the population on the rise
now is the time for us to figure out how
to include everyone in our business and
social interactions the first thing we
can do is change our events many
networking events today take place at
bars given my history a bar with
unlimited alcohol is not an appealing
place for me to meet people for instance
earlier this year I was at a GSB
networking event I was walking around in
circles without a drink desperately
trying to find the courage to join a
group to chat with and let me tell you
going up two groups of strangers at a
400 person event with no social
lubricant is really hard every time I
try to join in with someone new they
would try to give me a drink or ask
about why I wasn't drinking and for the
people I was talking to well at the end
of the night a lot of them weren't
making any sense
for me the experience was miserable I
dreaded going to future events but knew
I had to or risk missing out on the
connections and relationships that stem
from many of these interactions and in
these situations I'm one of the lucky
ones
I can still tolerate going to these
events even if I'd prefer not to my
voice is still heard but many
non-drinkers aren't so lucky and will
miss out on key opportunities by staying
away from alcohol focused events in the
name of self-care we can start to level
the playing field for non-drinkers by
thinking about alternative alcohol-free
ways for us to meet and interact with
one another
planning a hike or a cooking class
there's a team event in lieu of a happy
hour is all it takes to start increasing
inclusivity the next thing we can do is
think about the alternatives we offer it
should be just as easy to find a soda as
it is to find a gin and tonic
keeping non-drinkers limited to just
water or whatever mixers are on hand
well everyone else gets to choose from a
plethora of alcoholic options sends the
signal that non-drinkers are an
afterthought or worse weren't thought of
it all and I don't know about you but
when I feel like an afterthought time
and time again I stop showing up if we
don't show non-drinkers that they're
welcome they'll stop coming to our
events luckily coming up with
alternatives is a really easy way to
have a big impact earlier this year
all of us MBA ones participated in the
executive challenge it was a full-day
competition that culminated in a squad
celebration and a class-wide cocktail
hour as I walked to the room where my
squad would be having our post
competition powwow
I felt dread take over me as I heard
pops of champagne coming from every
single room around me great I thought
another time or I'll be the only person
not drinking I'd be grudgingly walked to
my team room only to see my squad fellow
sitting there with a huge smile and a
bottle of sparkling grape juice my
immediately changed I didn't feel like
an afterthought or an outsider what was
a small gesture from him completely
changed the way I saw my role in the
group changing our events and our
alternatives are just two ways that we
can start to have an impact but we can
have an even bigger impact by changing
our dialogue around alcohol about a
month after I got sober I met some
friends for brunch in San Francisco we
sat down at our table and a waiter came
over to walk us through the menu when he
got to the drinks section he joked if
you're here to have a good time here are
the cocktails if you're no fun here are
the mocktails a month earlier I would
have thought the joke was cute but in
that moment it almost reduced me to
tears
I was upset about having to quit
drinking I was feeling really different
from my friends you could all drink
normally I felt alone due to my
inability to participate in a favorite
group pastime I didn't even know who I
was as a sober person in just one
sentence that waiter managed to put my
worst fears into words now that I wasn't
drinking
I figured I'd be no fun later that same
day a friend at dinner started to make a
toast
I raised my glass of water hoping to go
unnoticed however I was quickly
chastised Cheers thing with water is bad
luck
I thought a lot about why I drank about
why it was so hard for me to keep my
Sunday morning promises for a while
alcohol was fun it helped me feel
confident when inside it was
self-conscious but most importantly it
helped me feel like part of the group
but all those illusions started to fall
away as I lost control over my
relationship with alcohol for me
drinking is no longer fun we need to
change the narrative around what is
normal and fun when it comes to alcohol
use making someone feel abnormal or like
they're no fun because they're not
drinking it's not okay
a good rule of thumb keep your comments
about drinking and not drinking to
yourself and if you hear someone making
a comment that might make a non drink
you're uncomfortable I encourage you to
be the one to step in and make it right
we here at the GSB have a special
responsibility to make a change as
future leaders Society will look to each
of us as role models we can start to
make a change today by changing our
events or alternatives and our dialogue
around alcohol so with that I'd like to
raise a toast with water because it is
not bad luck to each of us here today
each of us has the power to leave this
room and make a difference both here at
the GSB and beyond so cheers to changing
the future to creating environments
where both drinkers and non-drinkers can
thrive thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you